[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
he's wally zerbiak
he is a cbs sports college basketball
analyst he's also the analyst for the
knicks with the msg network and a
uh timberwolves sixth overall pick in
the 1999 nba draft wally
good to have you back on uh take me back
to i think you were in seattle
the last time seattle had an nba team
you were there
that was your first that last year for
seattle superstar what do you remember
about that
well i remember there was a lot of
turmoil with the ownership
and the franchise and what was going to
happen i remember we were playing in the
key arena and they wanted to get that
arena
redone or move arenas i love the city of
seattle i loved going there to play
there as an opponent
i loved playing there as a player and
living there while i was there it's a
phenomenal city it really is
right by the water there um i only
played there for five months then i got
traded to the uh cleveland cavaliers and
we made a couple championship runs in my
last couple years of my career
but i really had a good time in seattle
i hope they get a team back
but you're right the following year is
the year they moved to oklahoma city so
i was with the supersonics the last year
they were in seattle
and you were there durant was 19 years
of age
when he got to seattle yeah he was 19.
jeff green was a rookie it was a
rebuilding mode for the seattle
supersonics was durant great at 19
he wasn't this great uh he turned the
ball over a lot
pj carlismo was using him as a two guard
um
kind of running the offense at half
court so he was struggling a little bit
he still won rookie of the year so he
figured it out his rookie year you know
his shooting percentages weren't great
um but as his career went on he became a
dominant mid-range scorer
where you know a guy at six eleven seven
feet you give him the ball 15 feet from
the basket
you know posting up he can just turn and
shoot over anyone so
he you knew he was going to be great but
he struggled a little bit that rookie
year as a lot of 19 year olds do and
obviously he's become one of the
greatest of all time
if you had to choose you had to guard
durant or lebron
since you played with lebron whoo that's
a great well i guarded lebron in
practice
so i i i think i got a a few tips on how
to do it so i would have to say probably
lebron
i mean uh what do you want to make
lebron do
just shoot from outside you know that's
the thing kevin durant is a lethal
outside jump shooter especially from the
three-point line lebron
has improved his three-point shot
immensely over the course of his career
but as a defender i think for the most
part you can live with lebron making
threes
and making jump shots you just can't let
him get to the basket because he's one
of the most physically dominant players
of all time
so i would say kevin durant you know you
can't let him shoot from outside because
he'll kill you from deep too
uh he's wally zerbiak the former nba
player and working studio with
march madness how many times was your
name misspelled on your jersey did you
ever
did you ever have one of those moments
yes uh
i remember my rookie year with the
timberwolves we always had an extra
jersey thank goodness
but i remember my rookie year we had a
misspelling in one of my
games early on in my career and our
great equipment manager
clayton wilson in minnesota he always
had the backup so he had a backup to get
it right
the next uh that that night actually do
you have that jersey
i don't i don't um you know i think
clayton just took it and i think he
torched it
um explain the sequence at the end of
last
uh or the uh the ucla game where
you know you get the put back and then
there's that three seconds where mark
few doesn't call timeout
and i believe he had one timeout left
but in that moment
it worked out but is that that is that
the smart
decision with a coach with a freshman
who was getting the ball well i i think
it was a brilliant decision
and i'll give you a couple reasons why
first of all what a game and i was i was
literally 30 feet from the court you
know we were down there getting ready to
do a hit so to
be a part of that moment in real time
and be on the floor pretty much was just
uh
an amazing feeling for myself and my
colleagues ryan hollins
went to ucla so his heart was absolutely
broken there's a picture that's kind of
surfaced
with him grabbing my arm just like oh no
it's gonna go in oh no
and it's all over twitter and instagram
and stuff like that it's really a great
picture he's a wonderful guy and what a
run by ucla
and what a performance by those kids
honestly it's a shame that someone had
to lose that game
you know ucla just ran out of time like
clark kellogg said but
phenomenal job to tie that game up at
the end but
gonzaga is coached to win a basket is
made
to push the ball up the floor i mean if
you see jalen suggs
he starts turning and looking to run and
corey kissberg who's their four-man
and also timmy who's their five-man
their coach to get that ball
out of the out of the net quickly pass
it up ahead to jalen suggs and he's like
a blur i mean he's gonna be a top five
pick maybe
the top pick in the draft so he just
goes so that's something they do every
possession on a make
and i just think ucla just didn't really
think
okay we still got to play these last
three seconds out
you know if you can make jalen suggs
make one turn you know
stop him they just started running back
on defense like it was a normal
possession
and he's going to get the ball up the
floor in three seconds and then there
was no contest on that shot
i mean i was watching the play and when
you watch it in real time
you can just see nobody on ucla
was stopping him in in the backcourt and
all they needed to do
was just move in his way and he would
have had to turn
and that would have thrown him off and
he would not have gotten as good of a
shot and as good of a look
it's a credit to jalen's hugs it's
something the gonzaga bulldogs practice
every day that's how they play all 40
minutes they love to run on makes
and ucla had to be aware of that
but i understand the moment i mean you
just tied up a game in overtime
you know and the kids were just uh you
know it's a tough situation and jalen
suggs just made a heroic shot off the
glass but i think that's the point
though wally is
you almost relaxed a little bit because
you think we're going into overtime
like we had the put back we've tied it
up they got three seconds they're not
going to do anything with three and then
you all of a sudden
you see who has it and then he's got a
great look
and he knew it was going in
he did i mean i'll tell you and and you
know he was a step over half court this
is a shot that guys practiced we saw it
in the all-star game damian lilly steph
curry those guys were making threes from
half court to end
and the game and at halftime so this is
something guys nowadays practice and
jalen's hugs is a talented athlete
phenomenal football player basketball
player mr basketball football and
basketball in minnesota
so this is something that a point guard
works on and you know he knew
i had time he got it off in plenty of
time and wow what a historic moment i
mean that's the greatest basketball game
i've ever seen it was just phenomenal
and i can't wait for tonight the two
best teams in college hoops going at it
okay what does baylor have to do to win
this um
that's a great question i mean baylor
has the the offense i think to keep up
with
gonzaga baylor is a great offensive
rebounding team and you remember the
theme against houston was
can baylor keep houston off the boards
they did that
and they actually offensive rebounded
against houston that's something that
gonzaga is going to have to watch out
for because baylor has a couple guys
down low
and flo thamba chamachacha and uh
and mark vital who love to hit the
offensive glass and then on the
offensive end
the key is davion mitchell i mean he is
a guy that i love he's my favorite
player on their team i think he's a key
to their team
a great on-ball defender also a great
point guard
who gets dribble penetration not only
scores for himself
but he gets the shots for all the
shooters and they're the number one
three-point shooting team in the country
they shoot 41
as a team because he gets into the paint
breaks down the defense
sprays it out to those shooters and they
knock down threes all over the court
so i think in order to beat gonzaga
davion mitchell has to be
getting into the paint getting paint
touches living in the paint
and creating open threes for his
teammates how do you explain
timmy oh you know
i couldn't figure timmy out you know
watching him on tv
but being 30 feet from the court and
watching him play
i completely understand his game he is
the smartest basketball player in
college basketball today
really and one thing he has is huge feet
i mean he's got to wear size 20 shoes
i mean he's not overly tall i think he's
about six
nine six ten he's got long arms very
very
fibrous muscles and he has an incredible
feel for the game
i mean he he there he can go over his
right shoulder he can his left shoulder
finish with his right hand finish with
his left hand he's impossible to stop
one on one in the post
but it's because he's just so he's so
nimble as a big man i mean he just
his elasticity he slithers through
areas that a lot of big guys can't
really get through
and i was i think he is their most
skilled and best player i don't think
it's even close
when they need a basket throw the ball
to him because he can score on
any one one-on-one in the post and then
on top of it
he's so smart i mean how about that
charge he took in regulation i mean that
was just a brilliant play
at the height of like the game when they
needed
a defensive stop and he slides over and
takes a huge charge on johnny giuseng
so i just love his game and seeing him
in person
you can really appreciate how smart he
is as a basketball player those little
moves that he makes in order to give
himself advantages
i hate that charge call i know i know
too many charges in college right now
they got to revisit the charge i think
when a guy
when it when it when a when an offensive
player doesn't hit the defender
squarely in the chest i don't mind you
know the defender obviously has to be
not moving but if if if he hits the guy
on the shoulder here or on the shoulder
here and the offensive players obviously
trying to avoid the defender i think
you've got to start calling that a block
because that means the
offensive player is in control of his
body and he's not out of control
so when you're in control of your body
as an offensive player you're trying to
avoid that guy
and you still kind of are paying
attention to the basket
it's going to be hard to avoid contact
so i think they have to revisit that
charge call because
way too many calls are being called
offensive fouls when i think they should
be called blocks
well spoken like a true scorer
did you make your last shot in the nba
uh i believe i did it was in the eastern
conference finals
it was against uh the orlando magic and
i think i did i didn't have a great game
i think i was like three for eight or
something like that
but i think the last shot in the fourth
quarter that i got was kind of like a
little
a little elbow jumper 15-footer and i
think i knocked it down
did you ever airball a free throw no
i don't think so and that's what's
driving me crazy about luca doncic air
balling free throws
i'm like what's going on around here i
don't understand i don't understand it
i mean it gets crazy that professionals
shooting air balls i don't understand it
either and he's a great shooter
especially from the three-point line and
all over the place
i just don't understand it i think he's
got to just develop a routine where it
just becomes
you know just he's just such a feel
player like he shoots his threes off the
dribble
he shoots his threes fading to his left
sometimes fading to his right sometimes
that i think you know on the foul line
you just have to stand there luca you
got to get a routine and you just got to
mechanize that shot
and get his free throw shooting
percentage up i think she should be a
little bit better free throw shoe
yes i mean all these guys should be at
least 75
it's a free throw like just get up there
have some form
get a rhythm you know bend down like
come on
you're talking to the wrong guy i shot
86 so i i figured it out
[Laughter]
how many could you make blindfolded um
out of 10. hmm i gotta try it i've never
tried it
um i would think you know once you
i mean i can you know like jordan you
once you dribble you look and you close
your eyes
boom but if you keep the blindfold on
yeah i mean then it can start going
really uh really
sideways honestly like uh you know if
you keep the blindfold on i would hope
to make two or three out of ten
but if you dribble get your routine then
you close your eyes like jordan did in
the game
you know i think at that point you make
about seven out of ten why did jordan do
that
just because jordan just to prove his
greatness and probably to talk smack to
an opponent that was trying to get under
his skin that's what he does
did you face him when he was with the
wizards i did
yeah we had a lot of success against
them you know the timberwolves played
them twice a year
and i think if my memory cr serves me
right we went
6-0 in the three years where we played
against him did you talk
trash to him no
no way i had to guard him i had to guard
him yeah
you know as a three-man he was doing a
lot of posting up so it was a good
match-up for me i like guarding guys in
the post
and um i also you know played against
him in the all-star game and i made the
all-star game
my third year he was on the east i was
on the west we got that win too
but uh you know i didn't see the vintage
jordan of the of the 90s so
i saw jordan at the end you know when he
was more of a poster player still a
great player
but he wasn't quite the athlete that he
was in the 90s but you owned him
yeah i wouldn't say that he owns me on
the golf course that's for sure we
played a few times down in
down in florida and he definitely owns
me on the golf course despite being our
handicaps being right around the scene
he might be a sandbagger a little bit
though
hey great to talk to you wally and uh
enjoy tonight should be fun and uh
always appreciate you joining us
my pleasure dan i'm a huge fan keep
doing your thing that's wally zerbiak